which javascript framework is the best
if we go off of downloads react wins but
based on github stars view is the best
but svelt is the most loved framework
according to the 2021 stack overflow
survey and some people out there might
even tell you that you don't need a
javascript framework and whether you're
a new developer or have 20 years of
experience it can be very difficult to
choose which framework you want to marry
which is the single most important
decision you'll make related to your
frontend code there's no absolute best
framework and the only way to find out
which one will make you happy is to
build something with all of them in
today's video we'll build the same app
with 10 different javascript frameworks
including angular react vue svelt lit
alpine solid stencil mithril and vanilla
in the process you'll learn the
trade-offs between each of these
frameworks so you can make the best
choice for your next project this video
was a ton of work so make sure to
subscribe and hit the like button then
leave a comment below with your favorite
framework and i'll choose a few random
ones to win a free t-shirt next week the
first thing we'll do is build a basic
to-do app with vanilla javascript about
once a year a hot take will go viral
saying that you don't need a javascript
framework at all any expert web
developer needs to have a solid
understanding of vanilla js but even if
you're a javascript god attempting to
build a non-trivial app with it is a
recipe for disaster what you'll end up
doing is building your own shitty
javascript framework and the last thing
the world needs is another javascript
framework to build an app from scratch
all we have to do is create an html file
then add a script tag to the body what
we want to build here is a to do app
where the user can write some text into
a form input then submit the form and
have that item appear in the list in
addition we'll save those items to local
storage as kind of a mock database so
that when the user refreshes the page
those items are still present pretty
simple concept but there's actually a
lot going on there like state management
data binding events and the application
life cycle to think about the one thing
that all frameworks do and vanilla js
doesn't is provide a way to bind or
connect your html to the javascript
automatically in vanilla we need to
imperatively grab the html elements that
we're working with from the dom and i
can tell you right now this is a very
annoying way to build a complex
application as you can see here in the
dom we have an unordered list for the to
do's and then below that we have a form
with an input and a button to submit the
form now going into the javascript the
first thing i'll do is write some code
using document query selector to grab
each one of these items from the dom now
that we have access to the html elements
i'm setting up an empty array here to
represent the actual to-do items in the
list in addition to keeping track of the
data we also need to update the actual
ui when that data changes for that i'm
defining a function called add to do
that takes a new to-do item as its
argument now this is where things start
to get ugly with vanilla in order to
update the ui we need to manually create
a new list item element by calling
document create element then we need to
imperatively update its inner html to
the to-do text and finally append it to
the unordered list in the dom and as an
added touch i'll save the data to local
storage so we can access it when the
page is refreshed the problem with this
code is that the application data or
state is completely decoupled from the
ui itself and that makes it very hard to
keep the data in sync with the ui now
that we have this function in place we
need a way to call it when the user
submits the form for that we need to
register an event listener on the
forum's on submit event when that event
is fired we'll first call prevent
default to prevent it from refreshing
the page then call the add to do
function with the current value in the
text input at this point we should have
a working to-do list but one important
thing to notice here is that if you look
at the html markup you really have no
idea what it's doing there's no way to
tell this form has an event listener
attached to it unless you go search
through the javascript code itself which
is extremely difficult in a complex
application now one final thing to think
about is the application lifecycle when
the app is first initialized what we
want to do here is grab the existing
to-do items from the local storage and
render them in the to-do list if they
exist if there are existing to-do's in
local storage we can loop over them with
four each and call the add to do
function for each one of them
congratulations you just built a to-do
app with vanilla js but this code is not
going to scale complexity very well and
there's likely many other features we'd
want to add like routing or animation
that we'd have to implement from scratch
and that's why the vast majority of
developers choose to build their apps
with a framework first we have react
which most people would consider the
most popular framework some people call
it a library but it doesn't really
matter because it's a tool that becomes
the main driver of your project
requiring you the developer to do
everything the react way i don't mean
that in a bad way because react was
created by very smart people at facebook
to build complex uis like the facebook
ui react is minimal by design and relies
on the open source community to handle
other concerns like routing animation
state management and so on it's not
opinionated about how you organize your
code which requires you to make a lot of
decisions about which libraries to bring
in and how to make things maintainable
and scalable react is by far the most
popular framework with over 10 million
weekly downloads on npm and over 170 000
github stars its popularity alone makes
it a great skill to learn because there
are many employers out there looking to
hire react developers and you'll find
tons of other react developers in the
industry to collaborate with react has
an official cli called create react app
we can create a new react project by
running the create react app command
from the terminal now it's worth noting
that many people opt for other tools
when building a react project like next
js or gatsby that would replace the
default cli when you generate a new
project with create react app you'll
notice it has a package json and the
root of the project inside of which
there's a start script to serve the app
locally under the hood it uses a tool
called webpack to bundle all your code
together into a single javascript file
in react and most other frameworks your
application is organized as a tree of
components these components encapsulate
parts of the ui and have ways to
communicate with each other this allows
you to organize your app in a
declarative way where for a given set of
application data the end result of the
ui will always be the same now in the
app.js file you'll first notice a
function called app that function
represents a component in the ui and
personally i love the simplicity of that
now the return value of the function is
jsx which itself looks like html but has
been extended with an additional syntax
allowing you to insert javascript into
your html for the to-do list we can
define reactive state on the component
with the use state hook the hook is just
a function that will return us with two
values the first item is the value of
the to-do list as reactive state which
means any time it's updated the ui will
re-render to show the latest state and
then the second item is a function to
update the state now if we go back down
to the jsx we can loop over the to do
items in the array and render them out
directly in the ui as a list item then
below that we have an html form but the
cool thing about react is that we can
bind an event directly to this form
using on submit then on the right side
of it we can reference a function that
will be called whenever the submit event
fires and that function will update the
state and store the result and local
storage you'll also notice that i'm
using the usref hook to grab the current
value of the form input one thing to
notice here is that the html is a lot
more descriptive we know exactly which
elements our data and events are bound
to now the final thing we need to do
here is run a life cycle hook in react
that can be handled with the use effect
hook which will grab the items from
local storage when the component is
first initialized this hook can be
really confusing though if you're just
getting started to only run it when the
component is first initialized i need to
add an array as the second argument and
in my opinion this code is just really
hard to look at unless you really know
what's going on with the use effect hook
in any case react is the gold standard
for declarative ui frameworks but
there's more than one way to get the job
done next we have react's arch nemesis
angular which is developed and
maintained by google and unlike react is
very opinionated about how to organize
and structure a project it has 75 000
github stars and as the second most
downloaded framework on npm it comes
with officially supported libraries for
routing animation and server side
rendering and because it follows a set
of predictable conventions all angular
projects are structured relatively the
same and have awesome tooling to go
along with them in fact you are actually
required to use typescript google uses
it internally to build hundreds of
different web apps throughout their
product line it's a great option for big
teams but may be a little overwhelming
if you're a beginner to start an angular
project run ng-new from the command line
that'll give us a fairly large project
to get started that's already configured
with typescript we can build a component
in the appcomponent.ts file or we could
use the cli to generate a brand new
component automatically in fact angular
has the most powerful cli of all the
frameworks by a pretty wide margin and
you'll notice the component itself is
represented as a typescript class that
has a component decorator on top of it
now it is possible to define an entire
component in this ts file however most
angular apps break components down into
at least three separate files one for
your typescript one for the html and
another for the css
to add reactive state to the component
simply define a property on the class
from there we can define a method on the
class to update the state in addition we
can manage the lifecycle of the
component in the class by implementing
special methods like ng on init this
method will be called whenever that
component is first initialized now if we
go into the template you'll notice this
looks like html but it's been extended
or empowered with a special templating
language that makes it possible to loop
over an array of items using the ng4
directory unlike react which brings html
into your javascript angular does the
opposite and brings javascript into your
html then in the form itself we can bind
to the submit event and run the add to
do method whenever that event is fired
then to get the actual value from the
form input we can use two-way data
binding using the ng model directive
this binds the form value to the to do
text property on the class however to
use this we need to go into the app
module and import the angular forms
module there because it's required for
that directive to work and for that
reason among many others it tends to
have a much higher learning curve than
other frameworks but everything is here
for a reason and angular is very
opinionated about how to structure a
project that will scale well and that
tends to make it very popular with
enterprise applications and that brings
me to vue.js which is independently
developed and maintained by evan yu and
feels very similar to angular but in a
package that's more approachable for
independent developers it has official
packages for things like routing and
state management and a huge ecosystem of
third-party packages it has the most
github stars at a hundred and eighty
seven thousand and is basically tied
with angular for second place on npm
downloads vue also has a very powerful
cli for example we can hit the view ui
command which will bring up an actual
browser window and walk us through all
the different dependencies and features
that we can add when generating the
initial app this creates a really nice
developer experience but it doesn't
generate components and is just not
quite as powerful as the angular cli
you'll notice it generates a far more
simplified project structure but in the
main.js file we can add additional
plugins for other functionality like
routing or state management as it
becomes needed components are defined in
files that end in dot view the code is
organized into three parts a template a
script and the styles the component
itself is represented as a plain
javascript object and we can define
reactive data or state on it using that
data property now to change the state we
have the methods property where we can
define our add to do method that can be
called when certain events are triggered
then to tap into the component life
cycle we have methods like mounted that
will be called when the component is
first initialized very similar concepts
to react in angular the main difference
being that we're working within the
context of a plain javascript object
instead of a function or class in the
template we have a setup that's very
similar to angular that uses directives
to handle things like v4 to loop over
the to do items or v on submit to handle
the form submission one thing that's
nice here is that you can automatically
prevent the default behavior by just
adding dot prevent to this directive
instead of implementing that code in the
method itself you'll find a lot of
little things like that in view that
make your life easier and lastly we have
the v model directive to bind the to-do
text to the form input value view is
awesome and has a big community but
another independent option is spelt it
was the most loved framework on the 2021
stack overflow survey and has about 50
000 github stars it's not as common as
the other three in the wild but is very
well loved by the people who do use it
like react it's designed as a minimal
library and relies on the open source
community for other features like
routing one thing that makes it unique
from the other frameworks is that it
doesn't ship a runtime like virtual dom
to the browser instead it works as a
compiler to turn your code into plain
javascript when you generate a new
project you'll have a rollup or webpack
config if you choose which is used to
bundle your code and all the other cli
tools attempt to abstract that part away
from you when building a smelt project
you may need to learn a little bit about
module bundlers whereas the other
frameworks try to hide that detail from
you components are defined in dot spell
files and just like view they have three
parts the script the template and the
styles to create reactive state on the
component just declare a variable with
the let keyword then to modify the state
define a plain javascript function what
i like about this is that it feels very
natural it looks like regular javascript
with minimal abstractions going on
compared to something like react now to
deal with lifecycle hooks we can import
the on mount function from svelt and
register a callback for when the
component is first initialized now down
in the template we have a special syntax
that makes it easy to loop over things
like each to loop over each to do in the
array then to handle the form submission
we have on submit and we can also add a
bar with preventdefault to avoid
implementing that detail in the function
and lastly we'll implement two-way data
binding using the bind directive with
value followed by the to do text
variable in my opinion this is the
cleanest implementation that we've
looked at it has the fewest lines of
code and is fairly easy to read if
you're a javascript developer that has
never used spelt before the drawback
though is that the community is much
smaller than something like react so if
you need to use a supporting library or
if you're looking to get a job you might
run into some more roadblocks than if
you used a more popular framework and
the same goes for all the other
frameworks that we'll look at from here
starting with lit lit is a google
sponsored project that's focused on
building web components if you're not
familiar web components are a browser
standard that allows you to create
custom elements that can work across
multiple frameworks sounds great but the
web components api is notoriously
difficult to work with the cool thing
about lit is that when you define a
component it's creating a standard
custom element under the hood now other
frameworks can do that as well but for
most of them it's just an afterthought
and the developer experience is usually
not ideal if your goal is to build
standard web components lit doesn't have
a cli of its own but there is a starter
project to get us going i'm using the
typescript version here but that part is
optional inside the lit app ts file
you'll notice that it's calling window
custom elements which is part of the web
components api in the browser that's
just a unique point that you won't see
in other frameworks by default
components themselves are defined as a
class that extends lit element reactive
data can be defined as properties on the
class using the property decorator then
methods can be defined on the class to
update the state lifecycle hooks are
based on the ones defined in the actual
web components api like connected
callback by implementing the
connectedcallback method we can run code
when the component is first initialized
now one thing that's really interesting
about lit is the way that it handles
templates it uses the existing template
literals that we have in javascript or
in other words a string that starts with
backticks this allows you to interpolate
javascript into an html string using
dollar sign braces the end result is
something that feels kind of similar to
jsx and react but the html can also have
directives like submit or dot value to
bind to the form submit event or the
input value and as far as i can tell it
doesn't support two-way data binding so
i had to set up an event listener here
on the input change event to update the
to-do text whenever that event fires the
bottom line with lit is that you get a
much nicer way to build standard web
components without having to be an
expert on the underlying apis and that
brings me to an alternative framework
that is also focused on web components
called stencil this one comes from the
team behind the ionic framework which
itself is actually a component library
for mobile development that's built with
stencil they use web components for the
purpose of making ionic compatible with
react angular and vue out of the box
create a new app by running npm init
stencil and that will give you a
typescript project to get started just
like lit it will take each component and
compile it down to a standard web
component a component itself is a class
with the component decorator which looks
very similar to angular then reactive
data can be defined as properties with
the state decorator custom methods can
be defined to update the state then we
have life cycle hooks like component
will load to run code when the component
is first initialized at this point this
component looks almost exactly like an
angular component but for templating it
uses jsx like react that gives you the
best or worst of both worlds depending
on who you ask the template looks almost
exactly like the react app but it
doesn't appear to support two-way data
binding which means i've also added an
extra event listener for on input to
update the to-do text when the user
types into the form stencil is another
great option for building web components
but now we're going to move on to a
framework that i get a ton of requests
for solid js it's a tool for building ui
components and feels very inspired by
react but the main difference is that it
doesn't use the virtual dom instead it
compiles your code down to native dom
nodes similar to spelt and because of
this it hits very high performance marks
across every benchmark you can think of
it like a faster more developer friendly
version of react but the drawback is
that it has a smaller community to draw
from when you generate a new project it
uses veet as the build tool which is
cool then you have components defined in
jsx files just like react components are
defined as functions then to define
reactive state on the component we use
something very similar to a react hook
called a signal it returns us with a
reactive value and a function to update
that value we can then define a function
to update the state and if we want to
use a life cycle hook instead of use
effect we have the much more readable on
mount hook that will run when the
component is first initialized now for
the ui itself we use jsx it looks pretty
much identical to the react code but
i've noticed that solid does things to
make your life easier for example we can
bind the form value to a variable using
ref and unlike react we don't need to
import the used ref hook to do that
overall solid js feels like a more well
thought out and faster version of react
but now let's look at something totally
different alpine js it's a tiny library
at around four kilobytes that allows you
to extend your existing html with
reactive data and many of the features
that you would find in the frameworks
we've already looked at instead of
primarily focusing on javascript with
alpine you generally focus on your html
if you've ever used tailwind for css you
can think of alpine as the equivalent in
javascript it has over 17 000 github
stars and is a popular replacement for
jquery to get started create an html
file then add the alpine script to the
head reactive data can be stored
directly in a dom node using the x data
attribute that data can then be used in
a child element with something like x4
to loop over the array of to do's then
down in the form we can use x on submit
and also prevent default and then bind
it to a function in our javascript the
concepts here are very similar to the
other frameworks that we've looked at
but in this case we're working with raw
html as opposed to some custom
templating language or jsx now if we do
want to write some plain javascript we
can do that in a script tag and alpine
actually has a mechanism called alpine
store that allows us to store data and
share it between multiple components in
the ui that's what we'll need to do for
our to-do's so that we can load them
from local storage to handle that when
the component is first initialized we
can call document add event listener to
the custom alpine init event and then
update the data from the store when that
event fires and that gives us a complete
app with very minimal code in my opinion
alpine feels like an awesome option when
you just want to add a little bit of
javascript interactivity to an existing
html page but at the same time i don't
think alpine could replace something
like react view or angular so if you're
building a very complicated single page
application it might be best to stick
with one of those and that brings us to
the final wild wildcard framework
mithril it's also very lightweight and
tends to perform better than the big
frameworks it uses virtual dom like
react and view but the overall developer
experience is a lot different to get
started create an index.html file then
add the mithral script tag to it you can
actually create components from
functions classes or as we're doing here
a plain javascript object we can add
data and methods to the component as
properties on the object there are also
special properties like on init which is
the life cycle hook for when the
component is first initialized then we
have view to define the ui itself to
define a dom node we use the m function
and pass the name of that node as the
first argument then options about the
node as the second argument like the
class name for example or you can pass
children as a second argument like we're
doing here to map an array of list items
then down on the form element we're
defining a handler for the on submit
event what you have here is something
that is kind of similar to jsx but the
ui is truly defined in pure javascript
if you hate html and never want to touch
it you might like this system but
personally i found it a bit awkward and
the mithril app actually took me the
longest amount of time to build but like
i said before it really comes down to
personal preference and i could see why
someone would really like this and there
you have 10 different ways to build the
exact same javascript app there are new
frameworks popping up every couple days
so this video will likely be very
outdated by the time you finish watching
it the bottom line is that all these
frameworks can do the same basic thing
it's really just a matter of choosing
the one that makes you and your
teammates happy if you want to see
frameworks like angular react and view
in action consider becoming a pro member
at fireship io to get access to my full
courses thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one